Ich werde es einfach einfach machen.
Danke.
Guten Morgen.
Hallo, guten Morgen.
Ich heiße Köklike, ich bin der Dienstagabender Aser auf der Säkstation
und würde gerne mit Ihnen das Patientengespiel durchführen.
Sind Sie damit ein Verstanden?
Jawohl.
Danke schön.
So zum Anlauf, ich werde Ihnen jetzt ein paar allgemeine Fragen stellen.
Dann können wir zu Ihrer aktuellen Beschwerden übergehen.
Wenn Sie etwas nicht verstehen oder Fragen haben, melden Sie sich bitte bei mir.
Wie heißen Sie denn?
Ich heiße Karl Otto.
Karl Otto, Otto mit doppelte in der Mitte.
Ja, immer. Otto mit doppelte.
Wie alt sind Sie, Herr Otto, und wann genau sind Sie geboren?
Ich bin 63 Jahre alt und bin geboren 1960 am 1. März.
1. März 1960.
1960, ja.
Jawohl.
Danke. Wie groß und wie wie wiegen Sie es, Herr Otto?
Ich bin 1,65 groß und wiege 80 kg.
Vielen Dank für die Informationen.
Was führt Sie zu uns, Herr Otto? Was kann ich für Sie tun?
Ich habe seit 2 Tagen Schmerzen im Oberbauch.
Zugsweise mal hier im Bauch.
Wo genau sind die Schmerzen im Oberbauch?
In der Mitte oder rechts oder links Seite?
In der Mitte.
Das ist etwas, das die Schmerzen linden oder verstärkt?
Haben Sie bemerkt?
Haben Sie etwas Medikamente angenommen?
Nein.
Ich glaube immer schon mehr.
Also seit 2 Tagen habe ich das und das ist immer da.
Haben die Schmerzen langsam oder plötzlich begonnen?
Kann ich Ihnen nicht sagen.
Strellen die Schmerzen in eine andere Körperregion aus, Herr Otto?
Zum Beispiel in Ihrem Buruskop oder in der Unpersonbauch?
Ganz ehrlich.
Wenn Sie mich so fragen, dann strahlt das in den Rücken aus.
Ich habe das Gefühl, dass es in den Rücken ausstrahlt.
Ich kann es Ihnen nicht genau sagen, aber ich habe das Gefühl, dass es in den Rücken ausstrahlt.
Ja, ich verstehe.
Ich möchte sagen, könnten Sie die Schmerzen etwas genauer beschweigen?
Weil Sie die Schmerzen eher dumpf, druckend, götevoll für mich.
Welchen für mich?
Kann ich nicht. Kann ich Ihnen nicht sagen.
Ich weiß nicht, was das für Schmerzen sind.
Sind die Schmerzen verbunden mit der Nährungsbewegung oder Atmung?
Haben Sie solche Befürge bemerkt?
Nach dem Essens zum Beispiel?
Sind die Schmerzen immer schlimmer geworden oder bei der Bewegung schlimmer?
Ich weiß es nicht. Vielleicht wird es bei der Bewegung etwas mehr.
Ich habe nicht darauf geachtet.
Wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzskala von 1 bis 10?
Wobei 1 sehr leicht sind, sehr starke Schmerzen entspricht.
Herr Otto.
Noch einmal. Das müssen Sie noch mal wiederholen.
Wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzskala?
Es gibt einen Schmerzskala, es ist nicht so objektiv,
aber wir brauchen das, um diese Schmerzen einzustufen von 1 bis 10.
Wobei 1 sehr leicht, 10 sehr starke Schmerzen entspricht.
Wie können Sie diese Schmerzen einstufen?
Sie sind schon zu bei 6, 7 würde ich sagen.
Sie haben gesagt, die Schmerzen sind nicht in der Rübschenbereich.
Leiden Sie einen sauberen Aufstoß oder Sodrinnen?
Ich habe immer Sodrinnen. Das stimmt.
Sie brauchen 2 Kisten oder mehr zum Schlafen.
Aber die Probleme beim Schlafen, zum Beispiel einzuschlafen.
Das ist mir nicht aufgefallen.
Das stimmt.
Haben Sie Brustschmerzen, haben Sie das Gefühl,
ob jemand auf Ihre Brust sitzt?
Ja, ich fechte.
Jetzt möchte ich diese Gespräche pausieren und Ihnen einen EKG schreiben lassen.
Danke schön.
Ich konnte es ein Dringliches.
Wir machen jetzt Ihre Gluthochdrucknissen und EKG schreiben lassen.
Super.
Alles klar.
Machen Sie das bitte.
Danke schön.
Jetzt ist alles in Ordnung, Herr Otto.
Das ist bei der EKG keine Probleme.
Ich habe immer noch die Schwere im Oberwoch.
Sie sind bei uns in guten Händen.
Seien Sie bitte ein bisschen geduldig.
Nach der Gespräche werde ich Sie ein Schmerzblatt anwitzen.
Danke.
Vielen Dank für Ihre Aufmerksamkeit.
Haben Sie Atemnot oder haben Sie solche Bewege beim Treppensteigen?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Ist mir nicht aufgefallen.
Wie fecht ihr Sie?
Dann könnte es sein.
Leiden Sie unter Übelkeit oder mussten Sie sich übergeben?
Wenn ich diese Schmerzen habe, habe ich auch Übelkeit.
Aber haben Sie sich nicht erbrochen?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Haben Sie Beinödeme bemerkt bei den geschohlenen Beinen?
Nein, habe ich nicht bemerkt.
Ich nehme ja sonst gar keine Medikamente ein.
Ich verstehe Sie, es könnte sein, eine akute Probleme, ein dringliches Problem.
Ich würde gerne nach Ihrer Lebensgewungheit fragen.
Rauchen Sie, Herr Otto?
Ja, ich rauche.
Wie viel Zigarette pro Tag und seit wann?
Ich bin jetzt 63 Jahre alt, um ehrlich zu sein.
Ich rauche schon 30 Jahre lang.
Das ist aber sehr viel.
Wie viele Zigarette pro Tag?
Ich würde sagen, so zwei Packungen am Tag.
Ich verstehe, zwei Packungen.
Ich empfehle Ihnen ein bisschen reduzieren.
Vielleicht gibt es eine Möglichkeit mit diesem aktuellen Bechwerden.
Ich habe alles probiert, das geht nicht.
Ich rauche einfach zu gerne.
Ich verstehe Sie.
Jetzt möchte ich Sie über Ihre aktuelle Bechwerden etwas anderes fragen stellen.
Haben Sie Schluckprobleme oder Schluckbeschwerden?
Schluckbeschwerden?
Nein, ich kann sehr gut essen.
Ihre Appetit ist alles in Ordnung.
Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit...
Ja, ich habe jetzt nicht beschwerden, aber normalerweise habe ich guten Appetit.
Ich verstehe sehr gut.
Ich habe die Seite umgewollte ab oder zu genommen.
Nein, normal.
Ich würde sagen, ich habe nicht abgenommen.
Vielleicht ein Kilo.
Haben Sie Fieber gemessen?
Nein, habe ich nicht gemessen, aber ich fühle mich nicht warm.
Sehr gut.
Leiden Sie unter Nacht, Schweiß?
Nein.
Ich verstehe es.
Ich möchte kurz eine Zusammenfassung machen.
Wenn Sie etwas falsch sagen, dann können Sie mich korrigieren.
Ja, wohl.
Seit zwei Tagen haben Sie Oberbauchschmerzen.
Es ist langsam aufgetreten, im Laufe der Zeit immer schlimmer geworden.
Seit zwei Tagen strangen diese Schmerzen in den Rücken
und auf einer Schmerzschale bei 6 oder 7 Leben.
Sie klagen, dass viele Monaten oder Wochen dort bringen.
Sie haben das Gefühl, dass etwas in ihrem Brust eng ist.
Könnten Sie mit diesem Gefühl etwas genauer beschreiben?
In der hinteren Brustbein oder überall in der Brustkorb.
Ich trage ihn nur.
Entlang öster Fahrbrust.
Nein, entlangte Schweiße.
Als ob einer drauf sitzen würde.
Es brennt auch ein bisschen.
Nein, verstehe Sie.
Jetzt würde ich gerne nach Ihrer Vorgeschichte fragen.
Herr Otto, Sie haben gesagt, Sie haben kerngesund.
Aber leiden Sie an Vorerkrankungen, von denen ich füßen sollte?
Ich bin eigentlich gesund.
Ich habe keine Erkrankungen.
Das freut mich.
Nehmen Sie eine bestimmte Medikamente ein.
Medikamente?
Zum Beispiel Schmerzmittel, Baldrilen, zum Beispiel.
Ja, verstehe.
Ehrlich gesagt, nein.
Das freut mich auch.
Sie sind sich schon mal operiert, Herr Otto.
Eine Minute.
Ich mache erst mal die Frage.
Natürlich.
Eine Sekunde Entschuldigung.
Ich habe gerade bemerkt, dass ich ein Frage vergessen habe.
Darf ich eine Frage über Ihre Stuhl?
Haben Sie Probleme bei der Stuhlgangung?
Herr Otto.
Heute haben Sie die Frage.
Heute hatte ich Durchfall, aber normalerweise habe ich ganz normalen Stuhlgang.
Wie oft gehen Sie die Toilette bei der Durchfall?
Mindestens fünfmal.
Einmal heute.
Aber Sie haben Blut bemerkt, oder etwas anderes, ungewöhnliches.
Nein.
Haben Sie gelbliche Farbveränderungen bei Ihrem Augen bemerkt?
Ich glaube so nicht.
Jetzt würde ich über Ihre Operationen fragen.
Sind Sie schon mal operiert worden?
Nein, gesagt, ich glaube.
Nein.
Ich glaube, ja, doch.
Als Kind hatte ich eine Blinder-Operation.
Als Kind.
Sind die Operationen komplikationslos verlaufen?
Nein, das freut mich.
Sind beide Allergien bekannt, Herr Otto?
Ja, ich habe eine Penicillin-Allergie.
Wie leer gingen Sie darauf?
Das war ganz schön schlimm.
Es ist mein Hals ganz dick geworden und ich hatte am ganzen Körper Ausschlag.
Jetzt würde ich gerne über Ihre Lebensgewohnheiten widersprechen.
Sie haben gesagt, 30 Jahre haben Sie...
Nein, nein, anders.
Das ist perfekt Deutsch, bis jetzt überhaupt kein Fehler.
Ich würde über die Lebensgewohnheiten widersprechen.
Ich würde gerne wieder über die Lebensgewohnheiten sprechen.
Oh, oh.
Wenn man widersprechen sagt, heißt das, ich widerspreche Ihnen.
Ich sage das Gegenteil von dem, was Sie sagen.
Widersprechen.
Ich möchte gerne wieder darüber sprechen.
Da muss das dazwischen immer.
Ich würde gerne wieder über die Lebensgewohnheiten sprechen.
Ich würde gerne wieder über Ihre Lebensgewohnheiten widersprechen.
Ich habe einen Fehler gefunden.
Danke schön.
Sie haben gesagt, seit 30 Jahren haben Sie 2 Packungen vorgezeigt.
Trinken Sie Alkohol, Herr Otto?
Ein Bierchen am Abend.
Mitnehmen Sie diese Frage nicht persönlich.
Das ist eine Routinefrage. Haben Sie Kontakt mit den Drogen?
Nein. Ich nehme keine Drohmen.
Nein, das freut mich.
Leben Ihre Eltern noch, Herr Otto?
Ich habe keinen Kontakt mehr zu meinen Eltern.
Ich bin früh ausgezogen von zu Hause.
Ich weiß nicht, ob Sie leben oder nicht.
Ich kann Ihnen das nicht sagen.
Es tut mir leid, aber haben Sie einen Bescheid bekommen
von Ihrem Familie?
Ich weiß es nicht.
Ich habe einen Herzinfarkt in jungen Jahren.
Aber ich weiß nicht, was wir jetzt machen.
Ich habe keinen Kontakt zu Ihnen mehr.
Ich verstehe.
Aber es ist eine Frage, wie es für mich wichtig ist.
In Ihrer Familie gibt es eine Krebserkrankung?
Das weiß ich nicht.
Herzinfarkt hatte meinen Vater.
Was machen Sie beruflich, Herr Otto?
Ich bin Dachdecker.
Ich bin 63 Jahre alt, wenn ich berühmt bin.
Ich verstehe.
Ich arbeite davor als Dachdecker.
Wie ist Ihre Familie statt Herr Otto?
Ich lebe alleine.
Möchten Sie über dieses Thema mit mir sprechen?
Ihre Frau ist vorhin schon gestorben?
Ich habe nie geheiratet.
Ich verstehe.
Das bedeutet, haben Sie keine Kinder?
Richtig, ich habe keine Kinder.
Herr Otto, ich habe alle wichtige Fragen gestellt.
Jetzt würde ich gerne über meine weiteren Posts sprechen.
Erst mal werde ich Sie körperliche Untersuchungen.
Anstelle sind Ihnen Blutabend.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, ob Sie das haben.
Dann werde ich Sie ein Bauchultraschall durchführen.
Und einen Wieder-EKG schreiben lassen.
Noch einmal.
Einen Wieder-EKG schreiben lassen?
Zweitens.
Wieder ein EKG schreiben lassen.
Ich glaube, ich bin wieder immer falsch.
Alles gut.
Alles gleich.
Haben Sie Fragen oder möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Ich würde gerne nach Hause gehen.
Ich empfehle Ihnen nicht zu.
Sie sollten bei uns 2 oder 3 Stunden bleiben.
Warum?
Sie haben mich doch untersucht.
Geben Sie mir meine Medikamente und ich gehe nach Hause.
Aber Untersuchungen besteht aus 3 Schritten.
Wir haben gerade diese Gespräche gemacht.
Wir brauchen auch ein Labor- und körperliche Untersuchungen.
Das bedeutet, ich taste Ihren Bauch ab.
Ich höre Ihre Herz- und die Lunge ab.
Die dritte Stütte ist auch Diagnose-Verfahrung.
Wie Bildgewege oder andere Untersuchungen.
Und nach der dritten Stütte ist auch Diagnose-Verfahrung.
Die dritte Stütte ist auch Diagnose-Verfahrung.
Wir brauchen noch eine andere Untersuchung.
Und nach der dritten Stütte,
die Untersuchung wird beendet.
Aber bis jetzt sind wir in den ersten Teil.
Das bedeutet, Sie sollten bei uns bleiben.
Ich bleibe noch ein paar Stunden und gehe nach Hause.
Ja, das ist perfekt.
Vielen Dank für die Verzicht.
Alles klar.
Danke.
Haben Kollegen oder Kollegen und andere Fragen.
Hocam, bir Schen am Abend, bir Schen, was bedötet bir Schen?
Was noch mal, das hab ich das gesagt?
Haben gesagt, bir Schen am Abend, Alkohol.
Okay, ein Bier, S-T-H-E-N, bir Schen, bir Biracik, bir Biracik.
Ich will ein Biracik, ein Biracik.
Einmal durchschwahl haben sie aufgefallen, aber wie sieht ihr die Üchtung?
Können Sie genau beschreiben?
Durchschwahl, normale Farbe, so ein bisschen wie Wasser.
Ich denke keine Fragen.
Alles hat gestärkt.
Wie wichtig ist das Wort?
Ich habe alle Fragen gestärkt, aber keine Verdacht.
Könnt ihr alles noch anfangen?
Alles klar, fangen wir an.
Guten Morgen Frau Oberärztin, ich habe gerade eine neue Patientin gesehen.
Haben Sie seit für mich, um Sie zu vorstellen?
Ja, sehr gerne, fangen wir an.
Danke schön.
Herr Karl Otto ist 63 Jahre alt und ist am 1. März 1960 geboren.
Er ist 1,65 m groß und 80 kg schwer.
Herr Otto stellte sich heute bei uns seit 2 Tagen bestehende,
begroredierende und mittelen Oberbauschmerzen vor.
Er gaben, dass die Schmerzen langsam aufgetreten, im Laufe der Zeit schlimmer geworden,
und die Schmerzen in den Rückenbereich.
Sie gaben auch bei der Bewegung, dass die Schmerzen immer schlimmer geworden sind,
aber es gibt keine...
Moment.
Wie bitte?
Hätten die Schmerzen schlimmer geworden, können Sie nicht sagen.
Okay.
Hätten die Schmerzen, also entweder, nein, entweder,
hätten die Schmerzen zugenommen, oder sind die Schmerzen schlimmer geworden?
Also, die Schmerzen sind immer schlimmer geworden,
oder seien immer schlimmer geworden, also mit sind, ist schlimm geworden,
oder hatten oder haben zugenommen, sind zugenommen, no.
Nein.
Okay.
Danke schön.
Die Schmerzen hätten im Laufe der Zeit immer zugenommen.
Und die Schmerzen würden auf einer Schmerzskala bei 6, 7 legen
und sie klagte über Sortbrennen, enge Gefühle hinter dem Bruchbein.
Sie?
Ja, er klagte über Sortbrennen.
Er klagte nicht, er klagte noch, er hat immer noch,
ist es ja nichts Neues, oder?
Oder war das einmal nur, was hat er gesagt?
Nein, nein, das ist immer noch, immer noch klag.
Er klagte, er klagte, er klagte, er klagte genau.
Er klagte über Sortbrennen, Angina pectoris,
wie enge Gefühle, aber könnte es sein,
Angina pectoris für diese enge Gefühle,
Beklemmung in der hinteren Bruchbein
und nausea, ohne Emesis, Fragena, Dysbne,
Ödeme bei der Bein, Gewichtverlust, Fieber,
nachtnächliches Schweiß.
Ödeme, Ödeme, nicht Ödeme bei den Beinen,
Ödeme in den Beinen.
Okay, Ödeme in der Bein.
Oder Ödeme der Beine, glaube ich sogar,
haben Sie Ödeme, warte mal, ich sage mit denen,
wir sagen doch nicht Ödeme der Beine,
in den Beinen, in den Beinen.
Nicht bei, bei ist falsch.
Bei, ja.
Aber ist nicht schlimm, ist nicht schlimm.
Danke schön.
Ödeme in den Beinen und Gewichtverlust, Fieber,
nachtnächliches Schweiß, wurden von den Patienten vernein.
Und sie, okay, ist alles,
bis jetzt, wurde, sei bei den Patienten,
keine Vorerkrankungen bekannt.
Und nehme die Patienten, keine Dauermedikation ein.
Und wurde, bei den Patienten,
wurde, als er Kind war, ein Appendektor mehruf geführt.
Und sie, er sei allergisch auf Penicillin,
und er bekomme Düsbner und Zungenödeme bekommen,
dagegen bekommen.
Gegenbekommen, nein.
Alles gut.
Er ist allergisch gegen Penicillin,
und er würde, nicht dagegen einfach weglassen,
dagegen nicht benutzen.
Ah, okay.
Das ist türkisch, dagegen nicht weglassen.
Ja, ich immer denke, der ist türkisch.
Ja, alles gut, alles gut.
Er würde, er würde Schwellung im Hals und Auschlag
bekommen, reicht schon, nicht dagegen,
dagegen sagt man nicht.
Und sie, okay, er,
Entschuldigung, türkisch, er ist allergisch dagegen.
Aber er würde dagegen das bekommen nicht.
Man sagt, er ist allergisch dagegen.
Das ist genau richtig, dagegen allergisch.
Aber wenn man sagt, er würde das und das bekommen,
nicht mehr sagen er dagegen,
sondern er würde das und das bekommen.
Haben Sie verstanden?
Ja, ich habe verstanden, aber allergisch dagegen
ist richtig.
Aber er würde dagegen das bekommen,
dagegen sagt man dann nicht.
Okay, dagegen gehört die Allergie-Star.
Okay, woher ich zu Hause bin?
Genau, genau, genau.
Ich verstehe.
Und er rauche seit 30 Jahren ungefähr 40
Zigaretten pro Tag.
Und er trinke ein Fleisch Bier pro Tag
und drogen von den Patienten vernein.
Er habe seit vielen Jahren nicht mehr Kontakt
mit seinem Familie.
Sein Ernst-Familie.
Aber er habe gesagt,
dass sein Vater leider einmal Miokat infakt.
Er ist seit Dach-DK.
Und lebt alleine.
Er habe niemals geheiratet.
Und habe keine Kinder.
An amnestische Angaben
dort am ersten auf ein Gastritis
oder Ulcus ventriculi.
Aber ich bin nicht sicher.
Was ist die Differenzial-...
Genau, sehr gut.
Sie sind sich nicht sicher.
Also Differenzialdiagnose.
Was ist Ihre Differenzialdiagnose?
Ja, mein Differenzialdiagnose.
Erst mal ACS.
Ich möchte zum ersten diese ausschließen.
Ulcus duedini.
Und vielleicht pancreatitis.
Weil Schmerzen in der Oberbau
und Streitende rückläumen.
Was machen Sie als Erstes?
Wie wollen Sie am besten vorgehen?
Als erstes werde ich ein EKG schreiben lassen.
Am ersten, am nächsten Linie.
Dann werde ich eher körperliche Untersuchen.
Und dann ein Blut abnehmen.
Und diese Parameter ist wichtig.
Ein Blut ist falsch. Blut ist Mehrzahl.
Und Blutabnehmen.
Und für Laborparameter.
Blutbild, Entzündungparameter, BSC, AP.
Und dann leber Nierenparameter, wie immer.
Und Herzinsüme wie Troponin CKMB.
Und dann Pankreasinsüme wie Amylase und Lipase.
Dann Holistaseinsüme.
Weil aber er hat gesagt keine
verblische, gelbliche Veränderung bei ihrem Haut.
Aber ich möchte diese auch bekommen.
Gamma GT und Bilirubin.
Dann werde ich, wenn die EKG und Herzinsüme
nicht unauffällig ist,
werde ich ein Sonografie Abdomen durchführen.
Und wenn es auch unauffällig,
werde ich ein OGD durchführen.
Östrophage Gastrodendoskopie.
Das bedeutet also,
wenn Sie das erste Labor machen,
Sie nehmen bei dem Patienten Labor ab.
Sie kontrollieren die Laborwerte.
Und Sie haben gesagt, Sie kontrollieren alles.
Und zwar Blutbild, klinische Chemie,
Grennung.
Und bei der klinischen Chemie möchten Sie
die Leberwerte mitmachen.
Amylase und Lipase, weil sie den Verdacht,
weil sie auch eine Pankratie das gleich ausschließen möchten.
Entzündungswerte werden sowieso immer mitgemacht.
Und Sie wollen auch die Herzinsüme und das Troponin mitbestimmen.
Ja.
Wenn im ersten Labor das Troponin und die Herzinsüme unauffällig sind,
reicht Ihnen das dann schon aus.
Aber ich meine, wenn es negativ ist, haben Sie gesagt,
das ist ein Ultraschall vom Bauch.
Und Sie machen direkt eine Magenspiegelung.
Reicht dieses erste Labor aus?
Nein, ich brauche nach 3 Stunden eine andere Herzinsüme.
Aber dieser Patient hat seit 2 Tagen diese Probleme.
Ich glaube schon, es ist ein bisschen erhöht.
Aber in der Notfallaufnahme oder so,
ich werde diese Herzinsüme zweitmals.
Sehr gut.
Ich bin damit komplett einverstanden.
Wenn der Patient seit 2 Tagen beschwerden hat,
würde Ihnen das erste Labor erst mal reichen,
dass Sie mit der Diagnostik weiter machen können.
Und was ist mit einem Herzultraschall?
Ich werde diese Bauch.
Ich muss diese auch machen.
Dann schicken Sie den Patienten zum Bauch Ultraschall
und lassen natürlich unbedingt auch ein Herzultraschall mitmachen.
Sehr gut.
Als letzte Instanz, dann erst die Magenspiegelung.
Aber erst, wenn das zweite Troponin dann da ist.
Sehr gut.
Damit bin ich einverstanden.
Ich habe diese gelesen in der Ambus.
Für diese Gastritis gibt es eine andere Untersuchungsmethode.
Die Atemtest, Ureas oder Per Hachmedre.
Ist das üblich in Deutschland zu benutzen?
Nein, ich glaube so.
Dieser Atemtest wird oft mal,
mal schauen, wie es für die Gastritis macht.
Manchmal ist es einer größeren Klinik.
Ich mache dir eine Pyrametrieatemtest bei Gastritis.
Das wird nicht üblich.
Das macht man nicht nur bei, warum?
Therapieeinladen.
Ihr macht das auch nur wegen Helikopterpylori.
Der Atemtest ist pro Kontrolle,
aber es gibt auch eine Medikation.
Ihr macht das auch nicht routinemäßig?
Nein, keine routinemäßige Atemtestuntersuchungen.
Ureasetest mit ÖGD?
Ja, also für Helikopterpylori.
Das wird aber während der Untersuchung
während der ÖGD immer gemacht.
Mit Grobein,
bei der PE-Entnahme wird das mitgemacht.
Aber dieser Atemtest ist keine Routineuntersuchung.
Mit der ÖGD immer HP mit,
bei jeder ÖGD, aber das ist ja überall so.
Aber Atemtest nicht sein, ist keine Routineuntersuchung.
Danke.
Alles klar.
Ihre Kritik bitte.
Ich bitte Sie um.
Werde es richtig,
Peripheral Ödem über Ödem in den Beinen zu sagen?
Ja, ich habe es auch.
Er hat ja gesagt, er hat keine Peripheral-Ödem.
Nein, nicht gesagt.
Keine Ödem-Ödem-Üdem-Üdem-Übdeime.
Ach so, untersuchen die Beine nochmal auf Ödem.
Das hat er ja gemacht ja, haben Sie gemacht?
Und 30 Jahre Zweipackung,
Stadt,
60 Jahre Pakung dieses Jahr.
Stimmt, war falsch.
60 Packiers.
Ja, ich habe vergessen.
30 mal 2 Packungen, genau, das war ein 60 Packiers.
Ich habe Entschuldigung.
60 Packiers Nikotin, er hat recht.
Der SK-Dilogie, der weiß es auch.
Das war falsch.
Aber es ist nicht so schlimm, dass, damit fallen Sie nicht durch.
Aber das ist erdrecht.
Das ist ein 60 Packiers.
Insgesamt muss ich sagen, jetzt mal ganz ehrlich,
das war sehr flüssig.
Das hat mir sehr gut gefallen.
Ich arbeite im Krankenhaus, ja?
Bis jetzt, ich habe zwei Wochen lang ein Hospitations-Gemach.
In der Türkei, ja, ich habe Arbeit 3 Jahre lang.
Aber hier nicht gearbeitet?
Nein, hier ist zwei Wochen lang ein Hospitations-Gemach.
Warum können Sie so gut Deutsch?
Ich weiß es nicht, aber vielleicht habe ich eine Fähigkeit.
Ich weiß es nicht, aber ich weiß es nicht.
Ihr seid alt?
Ja, ich bin alt.
Ihr seid alt, ihr wisst es.
Sie meinen, es liegt an seinem jungen Alter, oder?
Ja, 28 Jahre alt, wie ich.
Ja, aber es liegt nicht.
Ich habe viele junge Leute gehabt, egal.
Es war sehr flüssig, das hat mir sehr gut gefallen.
Und sehr wenig Fehler, wirklich.
Gut, Deutsch war super schon mal.
Aber wichtig ist nicht nur, dass man gut Deutsch kann,
sondern dass man das auch fachlich versteht, wie man vorgeht.
Was mir sehr gut gefallen hat, ist, ich habe ja extra.
Ich mache immer, versuche, etwas zu verwirren.
Kompliziert machen, ich werde es dir.
Damit man das nicht versteht.
Aber das ist leider auch in der Realität so.
Die Patienten sagen, dass sie Durchfall haben.
Die Beschwerden sind atemabhängig.
Sie meinen das aber eigentlich gar nicht so.
Oder Sie sagen, ich habe auch Refluxbeschwerden.
Und dann hat der jetzt Angina Pectose oder nicht.
Und deswegen habe ich das so gemacht.
Und trotzdem, was ich gut fand, ist, dass Sie gesagt haben,
ich bin mir nicht sicher, es könnte eine Gastritis sein.
Es könnte aber auch ein Angina Pectose, ein Akkus-Corona-Syndrom sein.
Deswegen möchte ich erst mal ein Akkus-Corona-Syndrom ausschließen.
Und somit haben Sie die Prüfung bestanden.
Ja, danke.
Somit haben Sie wirklich die Prüfung bestanden.
Das war sehr gut.
Und das ist das, was ich, Entschuldigung, Özütle.
Weil der Patient hat gesagt, Bewegung abhängig.
Ja, das ist extra.
Es gibt keine Verbindung mit der aktuellen Beschwerden.
Ja, und deswegen, das ist das, was ich auch allen deswegen sagen möchte.
Es ist in der Prüfung, glaube ich, nicht wichtig,
dass man sofort sagt, es ist eine Pancretitis.
Oder er hat noch gesagt, dritte Differenzialdiagnose.
Er hat gesagt, eine Pancretitis muss ich ausschließen.
In der Prüfung wollen die Prüfer nur wissen,
dass man weit denken kann und sagen kann, das kann sein.
Aber ich bin mir nicht sicher.
Das war sehr ehrlich von ihm.
Und dann ist man sagt, das ist doch diese Differenzialdiagnose
und diese Differenzialdiagnose.
Und dass er aber natürlich als erstes das Wichtigste ausschließen muss.
Und zwar das Akkus-Corona-Syndrom.
Das war sehr gut.
Das hat mir sehr gut gefallen.
Super.
Insalaam.